This video covers key strategies
and knowledge that
will make working in R
much easier in the
near and long term.
Let's start by opening R. If we
want, we can type directly
into the console.
However, this makes it a bit
difficult to recreate our
work, so it's helpful to open a
new R document, also called
an R script.
We can open a script by holding
down Command and
hitting N.
Whenever you write R commands,
you should write
them in an R script.
Then you can send the commands
in your script to an R
console to be run.
For example, if your cursor is
unaligned in the R script, you
can run that line of code in
the console by holding down
Command and hitting Return.
To run a larger block of code,
highlight the code, hold down
command and hit Return.
It is useful to type your
commands into an R script
because you can organize your
commands, and you can run and
rerun these commands
quickly and easily.
You can also save an R script
so you can use it later, and
this makes it easy to pick up
where you left off in your
next work session.
Here, I'll save my script to
the desktop with the name
temp.R. Saving and loading files
in R can very helpful.
R is always looking in a
particular folder on your
computer, and it is sometimes
important to know where it is
looking so you can access
and save files.
There are two tools that
will make this easier--
getwd and setwd, which stand for
get working directory and
set working directory.
The getwd function will tell
you which directory R is
currently working from.
If you'd like to change the
directory you're working in,
use the setwd function and
specify a file path inside the
parentheses, where the path is
contained in quotation marks.
For those working in the OS
X, there's one more tool--
Command D. Typing Command D will
open a window where you
can navigate to a folder
of your choosing.
When you are done in an R
session, save your script and
then type q open parentheses
close
parentheses into the console.
As long you carefully document
your work in an R script,
there's little reason to
save your work space.
In the next video, we'll begin
creating objects in R.